okay so myelodysplastic syndrome what are the challenges i would address we don't cure all
patients we don't use autologous transplant maybe only chance for cure of this patient
is allogeneic transplant so where did we get in recent years um i think one of the problem is how
many patients you have that's how many different mds's you have there is also clonal evolution so
making the treatment of this disease quite challenging and very few of these mutations
are targetable then on the other hand i think another challenge is truly this is systemic
disease and i really like this idea of inflamma aging and autoimmunity and mds so we are not
treating just bone marrow we are treating the whole body in itself and not surprisingly given
that complexity is that mds
including
increasing with age, but also that the results and outcomes are very similar to those that we
see with advanced lung cancer in terms of survival outcomes. So moving forward, the goal of treatment
should be to prevent myeloid-related morbidity and mortality. And this is a slide show MDS natural
history study. If we just use definition of death and progression, then obviously high-risk MDS
patients do worse and there is acute rise. But if the outcomes are a little bit changed to include
worsening disease and cytopenia and need for treatment, we can see that these early diseases
like CCUS, ICUS also progress over time. And with that excitement is, can we intervene early? I'm
not going to go over this study. There are different agents currently in the clinical
trials, whether targeted therapies, metabolic agents, and so on.
That are trying to address this question, can we intervene early? And some of them will be presented
later today. Now, let's move to lower-risk MDS. This is now kind of complex three. What is good
that these days we have Luspartacept approved, we have Imetelstat approved. So this is all exciting
because it does provide opportunity to treat mainly patients with anemia and also give therapeutic
agents for patients who have MDS.
: Thank you.
: So we have had more than 500, now we have Imetelstat and so on. I think one therapeutic
modality that is missing from this slide is allogeneic transplant. Now, yes, we want transplant
immediately patients with lower-risk MDS, but this is progressive disease. And therefore, we
really need to be smart when to intervene. Sometimes we are too late.
In terms of Luspartacept, I think everyone here is well aware that these agents improve
anemia in SF3B1 or in sideroblast mutated, but also non-mutated patient in terms of durability of
response. This year on us question was asked, can we intervene early? Are the results going to be
better? And the investigators did post hoc analysis of the study. And while they were able to stratify
patient according to baseline hemoglobin, transfusion burden, and EPO level, to some Luspartacept showed
better response. : Yeah.
: And it showed better responses than erythropoietin in all of these categories. But also clearly,
responses were better, less advanced disease was. And it was not just in terms of number of responses,
but also durability of responses related to Luspartacept, which is at the bottom of the
slide. This is just comparison between. So earlier intervention seems might produce better results.
Similarly, Imetelstat has been approved as an oral agent, improved transfusion in the
patients. : Yeah, that's great. I agree with that. I think it's a good point.
: Yeah, I think it's a good point. I think it's a good point. I think it's a good point.
: Yeah, I think it's a good point. : Yeah, I think it's a good point.
: I think it's a good point. : Yeah, I think it's a good point.